hola soy tony de rose y soy un
informático de pixar en nuestras
películas la forma en la que nuestros
personajes se ven y actúan varía
salvajemente pero una cosa que tienen en
común es que no se ven computarizados
tiene un aspecto orgánico y realista el
primer paso para crear ese aspecto
orgánico se llama modelado
el modelado crea una figura virtual en
tres dimensiones en la computadora uno
de los mayores problemas de modelar un
personaje para que se vea realista
es que sus formas se vean suaves
sin importar que tan cerca o lejos estén
de la cámara la computadora trabaja más
fácilmente con formas simples como
planos y cilindros pero nosotros tenemos
que crear formas más complejas suena
como un problema complicado pero
nosotros pudimos resolverlo con dos
sencillos pasos que son fáciles de
calcular en la computadora
descubrimos que podíamos usar un
algoritmo matemático llamado subdivisión
para lograr formas más realistas así es
como funcionan probemos con un ejemplo
sencillo en dos dimensiones hecho de
líneas rectas y que está definido por
cuatro puntos lo primero que haré es
agregar puntos medios en cada línea a
esto le llamo fase de división
a continuación haré que la figura se
suavicen desplazando cada punto a la
mitad de la distancia del siguiente y
después conectó todos los ocho puntos a
esto le llamo paso promedio y ese es un
buen comienzo pero puedo hacer que estas
curvas sean aún más suaves repitiendo
eso división y promedio y luego otra vez
incluso puedo juntar estos dos pasos
división y promedio en uno
paso combinado llamado subdivisión así
es más fácil y lo más genial de esta
solución es que les permite animar toda
la curva al simplemente mover la figura
original de cuatro puntos ahora nuestros
personajes no son solamente curvas en
dos dimensiones su superficie está en un
espacio tridimensional pero se aplicarán
los mismos principios de división en
promedio a tres dimensiones y con eso
pueden animar usando solamente unos
cuantos puntos entonces así resolvemos
complicado el problema de crear curvas
al descomponerlo en pasos podemos
resolverlo con matemáticas